you said the best sketch that you ever
saw on saturday night live
was when uh patrick swayze and chris
farley
is that one of your favorites it's a
great sketch no you know what i was in a
debate about it with some people
they wrote chris farley's book which was
everybody kind of
weighing in on chris's life and what
happened to him and
i think somebody in the book said
something like that sketch was the first
step in killing him
you know which where he auditions for
chippendales
yeah because it was like he had no
respect for himself
by doing that sketch and it was sort of
sad
the controversy was it was patrick
swayze who's you know
gorgeous and chris who's overweight
audition for chippendales
the criticism was that the joke was
farley was just being made fun of
because he was a fat guy and he's not
just the fat guy he was one of the
greatest comics but that's why the
sketch wasn't
like what was amazing about the sketch
and what people forget
is that farley was incredibly
nimble he was an athlete and he danced
incredibly well in that sketch yeah
actually
and he had this fantastic energy and
like in a way it was like a very
empowering sketch and i think that's
what people
felt the first time they watched it like
look at this guy go and be
completely proud of you know unashamed
and
just going for it i think yeah i mean i
think it showed off what a great
physical comedian he was
he's an amazing physical comedian he was
an amazing
yes was he the highlight of uh
performers in that group of people that
you worked with is he the guy
i mean you know all right it's it's
impossible to compare i mean he was the
most explosively funny
person i think most people who worked at
that time would agree with that